Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters and congratulations. You signed up to receive your 23-A-B genetic
SNIP report from us. You'll just kind of walk you through some of the steps that you're going to get.
There's me, this whole series called Understanding Your D&A. I particularly don't like that picture of me.
Actually, it's a few years old, so it's a little deceptive and probably fatter and grayer right now.
So I'd rather use that picture of me, so if you don't mind.
So in this series that you're going to get, I'm going to try to give you just as much information as I possibly can.
A better fact, you'll be on our newsletter lists and you can always decline and unsubscribe if you don't like listening to this stuff.
But on the newsletter list we give, I just am constantly updating that and giving more and more updated information as it comes out.
And my purpose in all of this is to help answer your questions without you actually being in front of me.
So the more I think that you can be empowered with information, the better off you're going to be able to take care of yourself.
We live in a society now that if you don't doctor yourself and seek information for yourself, you're not going to get really good medical attention.
Could we agree with that? So there's not enough doctors and there's too many patients and you tend to get hurt into the system and governed by what the pharmaceutical industry says how you should be cared for.
And I don't think that's always the best interest of the individual.
So we want to take your questions and turn them into aha moments and light bulb moments for you without you actually asking us the question.
So the more information we can give you the better you're going to be able to help answer those questions.
Now I also understand that a lot of people are in a situation where they don't want to listen to videos, they don't want to read this stuff, they just want to talk to somebody.
Well that's where your local doctor comes in because that's really our role.
That's our role for our full patients, but we limit our full patients to pretty seriously ill patients.
I'll give you some information on that at the end.
But the purpose of this, the site up for this genetic review is to give you an ammunition to be able to take care of yourself and go back to your doctor and say here this is what I'm learning and how can I approach this a little bit different.
I implore you to share all these videos and such that you're going to risk be receiving over the next few weeks with your doctor as well.
If they're open-minded and they have time to study and learn, that would be fantastic and it's only going to be a blessing for their practice.
So I challenge you for that.
Albert, I would say the most important thing is never to stop questioning.
Always be asking questions because if you're constantly asking questions then you can get the right answer.
But one thing that I'll add to that is that you have to be also listening.
Too often we see people asking a question and while the questions being answered, they're really just thinking about the next question to ask.
That's why this video format is so beneficial because it helps mold us into being a good listener and thinking and putting things together for ourselves and being our own doctor, as I said before.
So this will be really helpful for those inquiring minds that really want to grow and learn and add this to their health care and see success.
So that's our goal with this. So that's our prayer with this.
So I had everybody before you signed up for this, you were supposed to look at that 23 and B agreement and I just want to reiterate that because I want to be extremely clear.
We just want you to understand our available boundaries. This is what we can be for you and this is what we just cannot be for you.
Our 23 agreement state, very clearly, what you'll receive. You're going to receive a video series. It's going to be just a few emails with some videos on it and the longer I have to learn things, the more videos I'll be creating.
So go to our genetic tab and look at the videos that are there. There are some of my older ones, but there's still relevant information and then and your upcoming emails that you're going to receive.
It'll also remind you to check your spam folder because if you're not getting your emails, you are getting them. They're getting in your junk mail or in your spam mail.
So look for those and watch the videos and learn as much as you can. You're going to also receive a genetic slip report. Currently the genetic slip reports I think are like 24 pages long. A lot of information.
So it's confusing. I understand you don't have to learn it all, but you know you can see where you're really at. You're also going to receive a patient supplement report and those are not generic.
So I go through every single person's snippet report and I go through and I customize an approach for them. It is based upon your genes only. It's not based upon the examining you because I obviously didn't do that.
It's based upon your genetics so it's going to be flawed. It's not going to be perfect. You need to take it to your doctor. You need to take it to heart. You need to take it to the videos and put it together.
Why did he recommend that? I don't know. Well, maybe I'm going to try something a little different. That's all your choice. So you are not a full patient that are office. This is just a genetic review, but it is going to be customized to you.
I don't just guess that you and I don't have that automated. The only that's automated in this whole thing is this video series so that I don't have to try to communicate with every single individual what a genetic review.
The information is automated because the information based upon each snippet is the same for everybody. Your snippet defects are different so you're going to have to do your homework and look at your defects in the video that's on SOD.
Let's say, and wow, I don't have that SOD defect at all. So maybe I don't even have to watch that video. That's great. But what I recommend is personalized to you. I personally, myself, look at everybody's genetic slip and I personalize their supplement report.
So that is personalized. But understand, genetic 23V patients are considered our full patients in our office since we again have never done a formal exam. So the purpose of reviewing your 23V is to give specific recommendations solely based on that genetic picture, not on their health concerns. So you're going to have to take it to your doctor for those other things if they're if you have great health concerns.
Okay, so because of our busy schedule, I apologize in advance, but you cannot call our office with questions. You cannot call our office with needs, even supplement questions. Why did he ask? Why did he say to do this?
I started taking them and I didn't feel well that you're going to make your own decision and you make a decision with your local doctor because you're not our full patient. We're making our best and do the best job I possibly can.
So you can't email us questions either. They will not be answered. So please don't be upset at the current time I get at least at least 100 emails a day.
So should you want to go deeper and care with our office that there is some availability with that. But you have to start with the first steps page of our website.
And then you start with a case review that's personally on the folder over Skype with me. And that is available. But it's available. You have to follow those steps on our website.
So that would be wonderful. What you're going to receive again. You're going to receive that video series. You're going to receive that's going to be an email. Okay. And it will be linked to our website with some videos.
And I feel free to share that with people. I don't care. So I mean, I just want people to be helped. So don't think that it's exclusive information. You can just share it. I don't care. Share it with your friends. Give it away. It really doesn't make any difference.
But that will help you understand all this information. You're also going to receive a debt slip report. So I call it a genetic report. Sometimes I call it a slip report. It's a genetic variant nutritional assessment report is what it's called, I guess.
And this is just the top clip of mine. Okay. But it will, it is about 20 some pages. Currently, you can see that the version we're on is version 242.
This was my take in the day that I filled this. But it is when yours comes out, it may look a little different because we might be on version 300 by that time. Sometimes we're updating this five times a week.
There's more information coming out on a regular basis and we are constantly updating and constantly trying to stay on the cutting edge. That's the beauty of this.
You'll be able to look at that slip report. If you know what if you want to keep it on your computer or the go through the videos, it'll really help you understand stuff. But I think I just want there to be a lot of moments for you. That's my goal.
I'm like, oh, this is why blah, blah, blah. Oh, no wonder. Well, this explains a ton. And that's a beautiful thing. I won't be able to hear that. But I'll sense it.
Over, you know, the vibes of the computer that you're catching up that the light bulbs caught on a different thing. So that's a beautiful thing. That's really what we want.
You're also going to receive a nutritional supplementation recommendation. And it looks something like this that will be in the email also with the slip report.
So you're going to give me a few days to do that. If it's over the weekend, give me a few extra days to do that. So don't get angry and call. I paid for this last week. I still didn't get it.
If it's been two weeks, you still haven't got it. Make sure you email the office that you tell me because it might have got buried. But I almost always get it out within two days.
So if it goes, it goes too much longer that make sure you email so that you get this. I don't want anybody to fall through the cracks.
And then these can be purchased through our website if you want. If you buy these locally through your local doctor, go ahead. If you go on our website, you look up the ingredients, you do it yourself, do whatever you want.
I don't care. I just want what's best for you. Okay. Just do what's best for you. If you choose to buy them from us, you buy them from our store.
This is a clip just from our main website, cuttersclinic.com. And you go to the contact shop at the big red arrow there. Of course, the page doesn't have a big red arrow.
But here, the big red arrow, go to the contact shop, click on that. You'll see a clip. This is a clip from that page. Visit our store. You'll click on that, visit our store. You'll be directed to this.
If you're watching this video, you already went to the store because you purchased this genetic review. But just as a reminder, then you can go in, you can search for each individual supplement right there.
Just type it into the bar. It'll come up and then you can put it in your cart and you pay for it. And it's just really simple to do that. We offer free shipping at all orders over $99.
As long as it's within the United States. So enjoy that. I think our cart is good. We're constantly updating that. Constantly trying to make it easy. I shop a lot online. We're trying to make it as easy as possible. I know what you're going through.
And I know this is going to answer all your questions. You're still going to have questions. Remember, Einstein said never stop asking questions. That's how you're going to learn. That's how you're going to dig deeper.
You're never going to settle for an answer. Never settle for a diagnosis. This is one of my quotes from a log time ago. Always look for the reason why. That's why we're going to be setting you emails.
You're going to be on our newsletter list. We're going to be constantly updating you. Now if you don't like to get that, I fully understand it. I respect that too. Just please unsubscribe. Don't get mad at me, but just unsubscribe. It's not an insult.
I feel like you got everything you wanted. That's fantastic. So I just want you to be blessed through all of this. Congratulations. I just wish you the best.
I just hope that this answers a lot of questions for you as you go through this. Just wait down beyond this for your next email, which will be in the next couple of days.
And your SNP report and your recommendation report, and then compare that to the videos that you're going to be receiving in the next email and the information in the following newsletters.
And I just really pray that this is a blessing for you. If you need further care, then you start with the first steps piece of our website.
I challenge you to read through that. You understand our fee schedule because we mainly see kids or patients and some chronic live patients and some and some chronically ill patients that can seem to get better elsewhere.
So it might not. It certainly doesn't fit everybody and availability doesn't fit everybody either. So look at that, but that's how you would start is those first steps.
I appreciate it. And it just bless you in the journey. Bye bye.